This is two weeks ago that I didn't get to do last week.
So we're gonna hit this one real quick and then we'll hit this past week.
Let's skip ahead to where we actually start service.
That's,
I think we're coming out to a welcome maybe.
Nope. Good morning, Henderson. I,
this is the day that the Lord has made. Let's stand to our feet.
We're gonna sing songs together.
Let
That shot moved with the guitar. It was good. It had good movements.
Intentional. That was good.
Let
Yes,
We'll see you breakdown. Giant.
Nice. It's good found. It's a little jittery, but it, uh,
it's opening up the right way.
It's a good shot. It's very obvious who we're focusing on.
We're not trying to frame people in the background. That's good.
I think it's important that we say this too. Um,
her auto-tune is what's messing up here. She's actually singing the right notes,
but the auto tune's in the wrong key. That's why it sounds weird right now.
If you're wondering
it's a good follow.
Skip ahead a bit to a transition.
Remember,
just be aware whenever your camera's being taken and then as a director,
just make sure you're communicating y'all doing this morning, um,
when you are taking a, uh,
camera shot so that your camera hops no, to not move
or adjust, I should say. Movement is good. Um,
but you don't wanna adjust while you're here.
700 kids. That
Is amazing. That's a good transition though.
So this next week we'll have kids in here. They'll be laughing. They
We're gonna transition back into worship. We'll
Worship through giving and worship through song.
Amen.
We've been taught church that if we do not praise the rocks are
gonna cry out. So we're gonna sing this part right here. I'm gonna start it
Off. All right. So here, um, to learn.
Okay?
We want, we're gonna praise him. And you wanna, so if we're on taught
Church, that if
We, um,
We want to invite all of you to
Come, this is one or two a great chance for, or the other. You see
What the kids have been learning for the week, the one at the middle iss,
and just pass that on.
We've been taught church that if we,
We will worship through giving and worship
Through all. So let's say this is one. I don't know if it is.
And then we're cutting to two here. Maybe the top, maybe, um,
let two be a wide shot. Uh,
cuz this long kind of wiggly zoom is a little bit like unsettling as you're
watching it. Um, so yeah,
let two be a wide shot and we can see what's going on while one
is focusing back. So one was on Katina and then we catch two, which was wide.
Keep it wide and then let one refocus on, uh,
whoever's gonna sing the next song. That,
and then the rocks are gonna that way we're not doing this long, so we're
Gonna sing this part right here. Yeah, I'm gonna start it off.
Very easy to learn. Okay? And we're gonna praise him.
If you wanna praise him through singing, that's great.
You wanna praise him through clapping, you know,
you are welcome to praise him any way that you feel. All right.
So I'm gonna sing it first and you go into it. Just let it all out. Let's pray.
Don't be like the rock. Let's pray. Right?
I can't
Hold back
My praise. I gotta let it out. I
Can't hold back my
Praise. I gotta let, I can't
Singing. Denise,
Praise. Yes. I can't
back. Yes. I gotta again,
To praise you.
What, what, what,
what earth was happening there?
What app? Praise you.
So I don't know what was happening here. Um,
but remember if you're, uh, running the program bus, um,
which is all you should be switching on the side screens.
They stay pro two the whole time.
And then all you're doing is switching the program bus.
If you're on the program bus in a situation like that,
you're just fading to black. And then whoever is,
um, running graphics is just clicking on the bumper video.
And so we won't,
all we'll see is camera fade to black and then that bumper video's just gonna
key up over top of it. So,
um, yeah, I don't exactly know what happened here.
It's a phrase. Yeah, that's the way it should be done.
So, um,
it looks like we went back and forth between a couple things there.
I will not.
Good morning church. My name's Phil Sali. Yeah, some of
You said good morning. Once again, it's, it's okay to do keep the,
keep the wide shot wide and the close shot close. Um,
but we don't wanna zoom this far, uh, every time it's a new,
a new shot. I can almost give you the feeling of impending doom.
Actually, mom's not here, but whoever that was, thank you. Um,
I'm the pastor of discipleship and Community. If you're a visitor here, I'm, uh,
I'm just kinda like a sub.
These are all good transitions. Um, so little things that we can work on
In prayer that he'll continue to come back and, uh, rested and,
and revitalized and and fulfilling the mandate of his calling. Amen. And so,
uh,
I'm trying to find a side shot. There we go.
Control our children seem to be leading
To the church. Okay, so here coming, uh, once again,
you wanna make sure that when you're cutting from front
to side,
Financially we're afraid geopolitically
Watch this
Potential war scenarios. We're afraid of
Things we can't control. Mm-hmm. Did I miss it or was it back? There we go.
Okay. So, um,
here we're cutting but we're also on the same
framing. We're afraid of from here
Scenarios,
we're afraid of things we can't control and our children seem to be leaving
To there and he's almost in the same exact spot. Um,
so things you want to keep in mind,
if you're going from a straight on shot to a side shot,
it's best to switch framing.
So if you're at a what knees up
on your front shot, uh,
mid waist I guess, or mid, uh, mid thigh. Um,
when you go to your side shot,
You would want to do like an elbows up.
You want to go close or my preference would be a head
to toe. Um,
and then place the subject just slightly in a different,
so like, we're coming from camera three now. So he's always, I mean,
typically 99% of the time from camera three they're gonna be facing this way
cuz we're at that, uh, house left angle. Um,
and they're usually looking straight out.
So they're pretty much always gonna be looking here.
And so it'll be natural for us to put them over here
in this left third. Cause remember we're splitting into thirds.
Those are your two third lines.
So his body and head are gonna be in this line right here.
And then the podium is like here, or in his case music stand.
Um, and that keeps the weight right cuz he's looking this way,
which gives us weight in the direction he's looking. Um,
and then it, when we have switched to a head to toe as well,
then it's gonna feel more natural than just like, uh,
it almost feels like your head has like it's a, uh,
twitch in your vision as opposed to a new camera angle. Um,
cuz they're so similar.
So you want to give them some clearly defined differences. Uh,
when you do that switch
Church, instead of coming to the church,
we know how to get them back and we do everything we can to make
All ending.
Let's stand together and worship him
And then don't follow, don't follow him.
We don't need to know where he's going.
So I'd just go to a wide shot and then have whoever was on one get on
whoever's singing the next song,
which in this case was not that one.
That was probably me that called that problem because I've been struggling on
remembering his singing songs, even those written down in front of me.
Those are good shots. Let's see why
That's
Good. Um, you know, if, if we nitpick you could,
uh, put them just slightly higher so that they're in that,
that middle third. Remember we split it thirds both ways.
And then, um, as you zoom out, add to the bottom,
not the top. Cuz we really don't wanna see the screens if possible. Um,
it's not the end of the world, but I'd prefer not to.
Looking
Very purple. Jason
Focus is a little off on this one, but
probably camera issue more than anything else.
That was good too.
So probably started a little too far out
and it's gone way too long.
And what a gift. God's grace that we can come together.
Like this is his body too
On this one. Just keep that,
keep that headroom kind of similar and then open up on the lower portion as
opposed to, like I said,
that's just nit biggie. It's not, um,
Not the end of the one. Shame on the,
and our assurance is this. No,
no power
Check the focus on this one. Something's going on with that camera.
That was just, just way too long. It's all, it was a good pull. Um,
and it was a good shot. I like how it starts here. Um,
but it should cut now.
It just goes on way too long. Um,
odds are you're probably gonna keep the camera shot up longer than you think.
So err on the side of switching more
and then dial it back if you need to. Um,
obviously in slower parts of the song you're gonna slow down, you're switching,
you're not gonna be going crazy. But let it be dynamic with the song as well.
It's a good shot.
Let's see that one again.
Yeah, so one thing to look for with your pulls and pushes is all of them.
Probably anything that's not camera one right now when it pulls
you're getting this wiggle. You see that wiggle in there.
We're also opening up an overhead. We wanna keep them in that center third.
Um, but yeah, we're seeing that wiggle as we're zooming out. Uh,
so either keep it steady or only do it on the camera. Uh,
they currently can, which is
Morning church. My name's Josh Del.
I'm at Deacon here at Henderson Hills and a community group leader.
And I've got boon wise with me this morning.
And remember it's okay to sit on a wide shot.
We don't have to slowly zoom up while the other camera's get in.
This one we can sit on that wide shot.
I'd rather do that than slowly zoom up into, uh, my name.
Ison Wise. I'm 11 years old.
You know what's funny is from on Sunday all I could see was this from where I
was sitting his shoulder of my life. So I didn't even know she was up there and
Changed so much over the last year because of God and what he has done in my
life.
Isn't God good?
It's a good shot. Well framed his
Faithfulness and his goodness, our only response.
Cool. Good work team. Um,
we're making small improvements every week and it's showing, it's looking good.
See y'all next time.